[Música]
el condominio de 12 plantas en surf site
de miami en eeuu o parcialmente
derrumbado hace 11 días fue demolido
totalmente de manera controlada este
domingo cuando se confirman 24
fallecimientos se suspendió la búsqueda
de 121 desaparecidos por el posible paso
de la tormenta tropical
elsa la demolición dará más acceso a los
rescatistas
la activista y académica mapuche elisa
loncón de 58 años fue elegida para
presidir la constituyente que reescribir
a la constitución chilena en reemplazo
de la heredada de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet y así inició la cuenta
regresiva para un año de en el que verá
la luz una nueva carta magna
y en france 24 volvimos a conversar con
aquellos que entrevistamos al inicio de
la pandemia
un año después les presentamos una serie
de reportajes sobre cómo han cambiado
las vidas de los contagiados pero
también de los afectados por la crisis
económica derivada de la emergencia
sanitaria en el primer episodio el tema
es el cob it largo
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y estas son las noticias de france
24 vamos a comenzar con la noticia de
miami eeuu el condominio de surf sider
parcialmente derrumbado hace 11 días fue
demolido totalmente y de manera
controlada este domingo hasta el momento
se confirman 24 fallecimientos y se
suspendió temporalmente la búsqueda de
121 desaparecidos la alcaldesa del
condado de miami-dade daniela le viene
cava dijo que los rescatistas volverán a
sus labores tras la demolición que se
decidió por prevención antes de la
posible llegada de la tormenta tropical
el sha
y honestamente en este momento siento
alivio siento alivio porque este
edificio era inestable el edificio
estaba obstaculizando nuestros esfuerzos
de búsqueda realmente estábamos
atascados y no podíamos llegar a cierta
parte de la pila les he oído decir que
creen que hay huecos en esa zona zonas
donde podrán buscar así que estoy
emocionada por eso
precisamente la tormenta tropical elsa
se fortaleció en la noche de este
domingo cuando se acercó al centro sur
de cuba la isla emitió advertencias de
huracán para las provincias de
cienfuegos y matanzas en medio de
lluvias intensas por lo que más de
100.000 personas fueron evacuadas en el
trayecto del fenómeno incluyendo la
capital la habana el centro nacional de
huracanes con sede en miami informó que
los vientos máximos sostenidos estaban
cerca de los 100 kilómetros por hora y
la tormenta avanza hacia el estrecho de
florida y pasará cerca de los cayos el
martes
entretanto eeuu celebró este domingo el
día de la independencia en su primer
gran evento desde su llegada a la casa
blanca del presidente joe by de nieve
fue el anfitrión de una barbacoa para
más de 1000 personas previamente el jefe
de estado entregó su mensaje a la nación
llamó a los ciudadanos a vacunarse y
mencionó los peligros que supone la
variante del está en el país la fecha se
conmemoró con más de 15 minutos de
fuegos artificiales baiden había
señalado este día como meta para vacunar
al 70% de los estadounidenses pero el
objetivo no se logró el porcentaje de
vacunados con al menos una dosis ronda
del 67 por ciento
en noticias de américa latina' chile
volvió este domingo después de vivir un
convulso comienzo para las redacciones
de su nueva constitución la sesión
inaugural fue suspendida durante una
hora por protestas ciudadanas pero en un
movimiento histórico la académica y
activista indígena mapuche elisa loncón
fue elegida en segunda votación o como
presidenta de la convención liderará la
redacción de la nueva carta magna que
reemplazará a la heredada de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet una salida
política a las protestas iniciadas en
octubre de 2019 en reclamo de igualdad
social
de la contestación a la constitución
la académica mapuche elisa loncón y su
historia al convertirse en la presidenta
de la convención constitucional que
redactará una carta magna en chile su
victoria fue ampliamente celebrada
puesto que ella académica lingüista e
inmisión activista mapuche la etnia
indígena mayoritaria del país encarna
valores de un nuevo chile esta
convención que hoy día me toca presidir
transformar a chile en un hitler
plurinacional e intercultural la
convención conformada por 155 miembros y
la primera paritaria del mundo tendrá la
misión de encarrilar a un país
fuertemente afectado por una crisis
social e institucional
[Música]
bastaría para vuelo
cayeron muy bien
la compañera
[Música]
lo que también marcó esta jornada fue un
grupo de constituyentes que se negó a
tomar asiento al comienzo del acto
exigiendo el cese de lo que denominaron
la represión policial contra un grupo de
manifestantes que se encontraba a las
afueras del recinto el encuentro fue
suspendido durante casi una hora
obviamente que queremos hacer una fiesta
de la democracia en un problema en
consecuencia yo voy a pedir un par de
minutos para que se informe cuál es la
realidad que estaba ocurriendo a partir
de este domingo el órgano trabajará
durante un máximo de un año para
redactar una propuesta de constitución
que deberá someterse en 2022 a otro
plebiscito con voto obligatorio
en france 24 damos inicio hoy a una
nueva serie de reportajes
un año después nuestros periodistas han
ido al encuentro de las personas que
conocieron al inicio de la pandemia
enfermos o que desarrollaron el cobista
pero también individuos afectados por la
crisis económica derivada de la crisis
sanitaria una mujer vulnerable una
limpiadora de casa particular un médico
un enfermo de cáncer y una profesional
liberal de parís protagonizan estas
historias los dejamos con este primer
capítulo sobre el hobbit largo un
reportaje de erika olavarría y alexandra
reinhardt
cuando en abril del 2020 conversamos con
virgin y esta responsable en
comunicación de parís ella pensaba haber
vencido al hobbit sin embargo la misma
noche de nuestra entrevista a la fiebre
volvió beer in y descubrió que padecía
de covite largo es decir un hobbit con
recaída
tuve fiebre muy fuerte durante varios
días y sólo sentía dolor no tenía
ninguna parte de mi cuerpo que no me
doliera fama la luz
esa noche pensé que potencialmente no me
iba a despertar al día siguiente pero no
no no
es violento yo lo que tenía que retomar
el combate con un corazón y mente débil
es mortal a civil y fax o no
el golpe fue sobre todo psicológico
mitin y perdió el cabello a causa del
estrés como su organismo estaba débil a
comienzos de julio desarrolló una
infección estomacal entonces decidió
cambiar de vida y mudarse a la periferia
de parís
yo necesitaba que hubiera menos gente yo
estaba en un lugar muy urbano con gran
densidad y necesitaba eso de encontrar
verdaderamente la naturaleza poder
respirar porque esa fue mi primera
palabra del año 2020 respirar fue
complicado
poco a poco bien y recupera su vida de
antes y deja atrás el miedo a la
enfermedad la vacunación ha despertado
en ella la esperanza
a mí con la segunda inyección nadie me
asegura que no voy a volver a vivir lo
que viví
y eso no es algo que pueda ignorar
hoy no estoy con gente que no respeta
los gestos barrera un gol tampoco al
interior de los restaurantes aunque ya
reabrieron jugada de que el club y
evidentemente no beso a la gente
virgen y si dio un primer beso desde el
inicio de la pandemia fue para su mamá
el pasado 30 de mayo día de la madre en
francia ella también está vacunada
información de áfrica en tigre etiopía
las fuerzas rebeldes anunciaron que
aceptarían el alto el fuego declarado el
pasado lunes por el gobierno solo si se
respetan una serie de condiciones como
la garantía de que no habrá una segunda
ronda de invasiones el frente de
liberación del pueblo de tigre quiere
una retirada total de las tropas de de
eritrea y del estado vecino de amara
antes de entablar conversaciones la
autoridad expulsada del año pasado por
las fuerzas etíopes y las tropas de
eritrea regresó a la capital de la
región mekelle
a lo que siguió la declaración del
gobierno más de 400.000 personas en las
zonas se enfrentan a la hambruna
y hablamos de la copa américa porque las
elecciones desde brasil y perú
disputarán este lunes a las 18 horas
bogotá quito lima el primer partido de
semifinal
la canarinha cinco veces campeona del
mundo logró su pase a esta instancia
tras derrotar a chile con marcador de un
gol por 0 por su parte los peruanos que
buscan su primer título en el torneo
desde el 75 vencieron a paraguay por la
vida de los penales tras empatar a tres
goles en el tiempo reglamentario
hasta aquí el informativo siga con
nosotros en france 24 y en france 24
punto com buenos días
[Música]